there's nobody that can put the Jets
on like him I think that tells you why
his nickname is fly what a Play What
a set of Miss it's okay here comes
tip here's a chance for a breakaway it's mantha to
the backand and he scores this is a great play by
Conor McMichael to set up Anthony mantha the block
is first by mantha McMichael picks up that loose
Pucket a little feathery dish to mantha behind the
plate it's the 6'5 forward goes to the back and
around Jonathan quick and to make sure he lifts
it into the top of the net it's a beauty and it's
1-1 moved along for Tan of Larson right in what a
goal hey hey what do you say big cat Adam Larson
with a thing of beauty oh what a sweet play there
by Lars just a beautiful play all the way around
how about that pass two by Turbo look at this
thing just landed right on the plate perfectly
started with a little FL but it came down he
was able to go for and back a little butterfly
going and it just landed like a caterpillar there
that beautiful got knocked off the punt by weager
and the other way goes Coleman trying to work at
the Sharon goic he's got scores on the back hand
what a Play What a set of Miss look at the pass
here by Coleman as well was across the offensive
Blue Line in control of the puck and then jovic
forehand backand and Tucks it right over top of
that Blocker on carala malol for Dylan redirected
nicely by the of ncai elers get coers shoots SC
I think that tells you why his nickname is fly
he's got a paper trail behind him off the rush
without breaking stride he Snipes this one past
braic that look on his face says it all and it
is shaken to C the light set Anderson forced out
of the pocket play back in by Pon for lin look at
that for check by pan that set the whole thing
up as he forces the turnover and Lin finishes
it off and it went over the goenda Dylan Lin
is becoming a master at scoring attempt from
close to the goal line absolutely had eyes on this
one beautiful Tic Tac Toe goal oh again kanes now
want to add a little bit more as Terin spins it
across and Tick T two in a row spech on a picture
perfect setup beautiful Tic Tac toall play speac
made the key play just outside the Anaheim Blue
Line we talked about AO and His Brilliant with
a capital bat playmaking over the last month we
also talked about the finishing at fchn COV
where you saw both on Flatout display have
to go in this ma in the nation's capital CU n off
it's bed in Nick Dow kets off gets outside of the
defense and as he flips it to the net Nick Dow is
going to tap this just below shoulder height this
is a good goal all kets off's work Dow who has
played really well of late for the C gets his
seven great hand eye coordination by Dow up there
by Riley he'll swallow him up to Center Steels
Morgan Riley St Morgan Riley basically does this
himself everybody else is changing a bouncing tck
on t a great stick and then just the backand
up yor has kind of got frozen here thinking
maybe Riley would go back to his forehand instead
just a little hesitation and a flip up and over
snatched away McDavid makes a move TOS it home
for the equalizer on a broken play at the Blue
Line McDavid somehow makes it work unbelievable
there's nobody that can put the Jets on like him
and navigate through sticks bodies and what a deak
around the pad I mean he literally just tucks that
around the right pad of lion to connect the he
chip it but hit the linesman it's got back by
tippet it across the line tippet dances his way in
the back hry he SCS a thing of beauty you got to
be kidding me what a move by tippet the initial
dump in hits the official looks like it's going
to be a bad om and turns out to be a great thing
look at the reaction by connect it's okay here
comes tip tip it picks it up absolutely walks
Justin F what a move a delayed penalty was going
to be called but the backhand finish by tippet wow
right up topers kale truway cross one time oh my
gosh the save rebound go what a backhand pass by
moo Ron and doesn't get better than that moo stays
with it on a slick play in batusin it's like deja
vu didn't he just score from there in the first
period yes he did cuz that's where he lives that's
his H and address weager huberto again makes
a move passing now off and in front they score
hatric goal jagor sharing Govich on the power play
they're moving it they got some creativity they've
got some confidence humido game is really hard how
about this play inside out passes down low home
with a perfect setup across the crease straight
across to Sharon goich and a beautiful passing
play with Dobson harass Matthews walks in and
shoot scores a doson giveaway winds up in the back
of the net and Austin Matthews has done it bber
doesn't go for a change he wants to put pressure
one more time quick stick turns it over on doson
and that is not the player to turn the puck over
to four check and Matthews opens up five hole and
slides it through and get themselves ready if
it comes off hot like that strong entry from
Power C into CR scores JJ PKA they came with speed
they came in hot what a move right there by Dylan
cousins stepping pass his man regaining control of
the pck tape to tape and JJ Peta right there and
he's able to just to dump it behind the golender
had to Brock Bess onto the left wing Alias Pon
steps over the Blue Line nice move to the middle
Pon impressor scores L Tang's fighting away with
Quinn Hughes he doesn't leave the forch and as
this Puck comes around watch her quickley it goes
heroic besser now it's gone up the wing Pon makes
this awesome move guess what that's on the forward
that's back because the Tank's behind the net Pon
walks around and Brock besser's in the crease to
tap it in what a terrific play Reinhardt over the
Blue Line gives jabarov 5 seconds left in overtime
here's Reinhardt on the doorstep for the B stores
let's go home baby it seemed like the Panthers
State knew how much time was on the clock bark off
down low and all kinds of room Reinhardt smartly
takes that ice the backand and he just roofs that
thing top cheese could try to find his way not out
here's Drew drops it for R it toon HS looks dle
shoots and scores up his back fat he snaps a rist
shot by Jones I think Jones may have not expected
this to come how it did you can't get a ton of
mustard on it but to get that much inertia off of
your back heel poting in over the glove through
a screen that's McKinnon magic at its finest mour
shot in front there's the CH up Sam Reinhardt does
it again he is just Unstoppable a lot of credits
got to go to kachuck you'll see a n look pass not
a defense in the league can stop this Panthers up
top patient right to kachuck and between the legs
to Reinhardt that freezes the defense nothing
they can do about that loose in for Kane he
scores show time busted up play kan's in the
middle of that he's asking for the puck he got
a fortunate boun holy well watch Kane make that
move back to his forehand and hardly touches the
goenda his first goal for Kane in seven pressure
by Coleman forcing a turnover and a good play
across to mapani backin going to the goal there's
the pass backland scores Michael backland this
move is sick but it all starts with Coleman way
at the other end doing some wonderful war on the
half boards keeps the Play Alive back and then
will go right to the net and how about that pass
I mean that is beautiful Pon with a beautiful
setup to find backin here settles a buck down
perfect pass that is a beautiful move by backin
drops it back to Mo the shot safe rebound bed in
they score and paling the first one through the
line one thing about huler in this game tonight
there's been rebounds to be had this one here is
a shot that huler should catch he doesn't and a
little Bank play there by paling as he puts it
off of kyou and in the net second Ducks break
back ter to the middle of the ice and he shoves
a backhander stole ours to tie the Game Boy The
question as he made his way across the slot was
whether he could settle the puck to get a shot
away the answer is yes he manages somehow to hoist
that up short side there was not much room up top
look where he puts it top sh great finish by Troy
josa chasing it down Luger will come up with it
waiting for a Garland in front and Conor Garland
makes it 2-1 all alone from the slot Luger does
great work in the corner to center it to Garland
Garland who's waiting he gets it from from there
pretty good chance it's going into the back of
the net you're right Sammy what a pass from Teddy
bler oh man there sets It app play in for score oh
what a pass from Panera nro doesn't get any better
than that talk beautiful this is beautiful he'll
just drift over and he'll be looking to his right
look at him look at us he's looking at us where
is he and then just throws it right across his
body he knew exactly where troch was he fooled
everyone with his eyes and that gorgeous pass
made it an easy goal with the Vander Kee over
the line hits the trailer eole back to Bard on
to dry CLE back this is just nice passing here
by Evon it's Bard with a nice play back Patience
by eckholm and then the backhand by drle throws
it through he gets a bounce and it finds its way
[Music]
home [Music] oh